what's going on guys this is Rob and it
occurred to me recently that I have very
little face time on Mike on my channel
but I kind of feel like it'd be cool to
to bump that up a little bit you know so
I like the idea of just kind of talking
to you guys about stuff you know about
things that involve coloring books and
so on and so forth I'm still just
explaining things I mean this will be an
explanation of source we're just talking
about things that I think are kind of
cool in this video I want to talk about
infinity war and I want to talk about
Thor's new hammer Stormbreaker almost
said storms new hammer for thoris new
hammer Stormbreaker ah this is cool now
for those people who are familiar with
Marvel Comics you probably know the
significance of this but for those guys
who don't Stormbreaker is well really
it's kind of its kind of a landmark
thing so back in the four issues 354 to
357 I think it was maybe was 37 to 359 I
can't remember
anyway back it wouldn't Walt Simonson
was writing Thor he introduced a
character by the name of beta ray bill
now beta ray bill is one of the most
important characters in the history of
Marvel Comics because beta ray bill was
the first person in Marvel Comics to
lift Thor's hammer now we'll talk about
the significance of that here in a
second but in terms of what this means
for the MCU we know that right now
Thor's hammer Mjolnir is basically
broken it's destroyed there's there's no
there well it seems like there's no real
bringing it back but it is a mainstay of
its character it's like Captain America
without the shield
it's like Wolverine without adamantium
claws it's a part is part and parcel of
who he is it's one of the most
recognizable attributes of this
character to get rid of that seems
almost kind of like like destroying the
character to a degree like eliminating a
core part of who the Thor character is
regardless of who's playing the role of
Thor who the Thor character is and so I
think that that the hammer will make its
return in the MCU like it'll it'll it'll
show back up and when it does what's
gonna happen with Thor's new hammer now
here's how I think that's gonna play out
one of the things that people tend to
forget when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is that at the end of
the day it all really is just world
building that's the basis of the MCU
it's confined to world building with
regards to like the Avengers Black Widow
you know ha
Captain America for Incredible Hulk
different things like that but it is
basically world building I would go as
far as to say the introduction of
Stormbreaker is like a more scaled-down
version of like an origin film right I
mean let's take for example Captain
America so we know that when Marvel
announced they want to bring Captain
America into the MCU it was like okay
we're gonna see Captain America
basically the de facto leader of the
Avengers
what this meant was they had to do an
origin story form they had to tell us
how Steve Rogers became Captain America
that's the first film at the end of the
first film we got a post-credits scene I
really kind of like an end scene where
he goes on to basically wake up in the
modern day and that segues into the
modern-day Captain America as we must
recognize him but the first movie sets
the character up the second building a
second movie turns them into the
character that we know the only really
exception to that is Iron Man and the
reason why that works for Iron Man is
because with his character he is he was
kind of the start of the MCU so they
really kind of had to go for broke they
really couldn't just like create an
origin story and then in the movie on
him becoming Iron Man he had to become
Iron Man halfway through and it worked
you know it served his purpose but the
fact remains here when it comes to
Stormbreaker I would say this
introduction of this hammer in the MCU
is not for Thor I mean Thor's gonna use
it but it doesn't serve the purpose of
saying like this is Thor's new weapon if
serves the purpose of saying this is a
new weapon temporarily until he gets his
new hammer back or gets his old hammer
back and then what he'll get and then
what will happen is like Stormbreaker
will pass on to beta ray bill I think
that's what this is designed to do is to
bring beta ray bill into the MCU now one
of the big questions people will have is
well how do you make that work beta ray
bill has never been introduced before
how do you introduce him into the MCU in
all honesty you introduce him with it
with infinity war and that seems to be
the significance of this movie that's
the cool thing we're gonna see a lot of
superheroes in infinity where we're
gonna see you know 60 70 different
superheroes in infinity war but I think
this movie is going to serve the purpose
of kind of setting the stage for the
next phase and the MCU that's what
Avengers 1 did Avengers 1 saw all the
superheroes we've seen so far team-up
and then in turn that set the stage for
the next phase of the MCU which is well
what happens now that they're all teamed
up you know what kind of events can we
see unfolding and different things like
that what kind of dynamics of the
individual characters will they mesh
will they not mesh back that's basically
what what that movie was designed to do
I think what infinity wars were going to
do is give us beta ray bill in the exact
same capacity that we got from Walt
Simonson but with the circumstances
slightly modified so in the original
Walt Simonson story what ended up
happening the way he wrote this out beta
ray bill was kind of like a protector a
leader of sorts for a race called the
Corbin Isaac and they were leaving what
used to be their homeworld and setting
out for greener pastures setting out for
a better world but during this whole
travel you know this whole movement from
one place to the next
Micke theory at shield had picked up the
fact that this ship was passing through
the solar system
and he contacted Thor to check it out so
we since Thor over for Encounters beta
ray bill beta ray bill believes at four
is an enemy against the korbinites since
you know maybe Wade bills job is to
protect everybody the two of them get
into a scuffle beta ray bill overpowers
Thor now back then when the story was
told Thor had this caveat and the idea
was that if he lost his hammer for 60
seconds then he would turn back into
Donald Blake and so what ended up
happening is he lost possession of his
hammer and then beta ray bill picked it
up and that was huge when that happened
I mean I wasn't old I wasn't reading
comics at the time when that happened
but from what I gather looking at
letters pages and looking at different
articles and reading books find les
Daniels and all the different things
that go into like the history of comics
it was massive when that took place it
was landmark because no one had ever
lifted for his hammer before it was like
he was the only one that could do it and
so because of that this ultimately led
to ode and bringing the two of them to a
scart than having them engage in a
battle of source whoever won would
basically be allowed to wield what would
be allowed to wield Mjolnir will become
the new Thor now I want to say that that
Odin Sun 1 and beta ray bill was given
Stormbreaker by Odin because Odin
basically look into his heart and
realized that his motives were true that
he was there as a protector he wasn't
really there as like a villain or
anything like that
and so going forward beta ray bill had
his own hammer it looks slightly
different from from what will actually
look to started striking difference
Waikele different from the owner but
still he had his own hammer and he would
show up from Tom at home he was kind of
like this blood brother you know hit him
he and Thor had this Blood Pact the two
of them would always stand side-by-side
if at all possible you know when Thor
called out for help beta ray bill would
always answer if it was you know
remotely possible and there have been
circumstances where that hasn't happened
but for the most part it's just away
from all to kind of bring his character
in and then have them facing a faceoff
alongside Thor but I think that's what's
gonna happen in the MCU
instead of it being the korbinites it
could just be like like you know that
beta ray bill is basic
a protector of what's left - like the
Nova Corps right like we know that for
example that Thanos is going to get the
Power Stone most likely he already has
it and I think what's gonna happen is
this gonna show it's gonna show Thanos
just decimating the Nova Corps because
if we're being honest with ourselves so
those guys who don't know who don't who
don't read Marvel Comics no way the Nova
Corps stands a chance against Thanos no
not a chance I mean they're they're cool
and it's interesting but like if Thanos
shows up on like on the the on the Nova
Corps homeworld never problem whatever
you want to call it was actually Xander
in the in the comics but if he shows up
on Xander and says like it's time for us
to like it's time for me to get the
Power Stone then like whoa we tied the
poor souls who are on that planet at
that time because like they're all gonna
die like that's that's just the way it
is and so like so they know so most
likely just decimates and are getting
the soul stone or I'm sorry getting the
Power Stone and in turn I mentioned beta
bread bill being a protector of what's
left not that he'll be a nova but he'll
be a distal protector or so or like one
of the people who's there and some
circumstance may arise something may
happen he may or may not pick up Thor's
hammer but the idea is that denill set
the introduction for some character now
in terms of what that leads into it with
regards to like how we actually lift the
hammer of Thor whether he becomes worthy
or something like that honestly I kind
of feel like the significance of data
revealed lifting the hammer of Thor was
somewhat squandered on vision visions
cool but it wasn't necessary for vision
to pick up the hammer of Thor to show us
significance he could have done that in
any number of ways it was interesting
but I kind of felt like that should have
been left to beta ray bill I think it
really would have like put his character
on the map because it's one thing for
Marvel to introduce you know beta ray
bill into the into the movies and say
hey here's this guy who gets like the
old hammer of Thor and for people to be
like well that's cool and then it's
another film to say like he gets the old
hammer of Thor because or he gets the
new hammer of Thor he gets Stormbreaker
because he lifted for his old hammer
then people are just like whoa that's
crazy like that that would be kind of a
big deal to me so I'm really hoping that
that ends up you know that that turns
out to be the case and again all that I
think really comes out of infinity war I
mean if really if Avengers if infinity
war ends away I think it will it will
end with Thanos blinking out half the
life in the universe that will segue
into Avengers for it
Avengers for will most likely give us if
it ends like the comics dead it'll
basically well I won't ruin that
but basically it'll set to things like
things being set back to rights
essentially and I think what'll happen
is with things being set back to rights
Thor will get his old hammer back he'll
get me on your back it'll be reformed
or something along those lines and then
you won't have a reason for store
breaker anymore and it'll pass on the
beta ray bill about whatever manner and
whatever but again you know I'm just
kind of spitballing here I'm just kind
of throwing my thoughts out here I mean
there's no absolute standard to this
because we don't know well we don't have
an absolute absolute rule here there's a
lot of cool possibilities that can come
out of Infinity Ward because what you're
doing is you're you know what Marvel's
doing is we're creating a story that
deals with reality warping and with
reality warping comes the ability to
create anything you want to or to fix
anything you want to the movie could
basically just be like a giant retcon
that's really what it could be
you know infinity war ends and then
Avengers 4 happens and Avengers 4 ends
and is okay so like because of the
Infinity Gauntlet we get back all the
villains that we really love do all the
villains we don't really care about stay
dead
and then like here's some new stuff you
know and some things happen and so on so
you know you can you can literally use
the power of the Infinity gone on in
that film to just kind of make whatever
you want to and it works because you're
talking about universe level reality
warping so again there's a lot of
possibilities here and I just want to
kind of throw that out there you know
but I'm curious I'm curious what you
guys think about this whole thing like
like what's your stance on this do you
guys agree do you guys disagree you guys
think that that infinity war will be
cool with regards to like seeing seeing
people die and like stuff get destroyed
but do you think that like Stormbreaker
will just be Stormbreaker it'll be
destroyed Thor I'll get me on their back
and you think we'll never see beta ray
bill I'm kind of curious what your all
stance is on this but if you guys are
new here to comment explain it make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace